there were 70 million
of these dropped by a allied air force
the
american airport and it gives the name
of
12 different cities it says we have a
bomb
that has more powerful that is more
powerful than
all of the weaponry we have dropped in
europe
in one bomb if you're in one of these 12
cities
nagasaki and uh and hiroshima were two
of those
cities please leave now
a couple of other things i think change
history
you know what this is have you ever seen
this i mean this it's got to be well
there's japanese markings on there right
well that's not dropping of no no it's
certainly not the dropping of the
nukes okay but that's what this is about
yeah okay
the back okay there were
70 million of these dropped
by a allied air force the american
airport
and it gives the name of 12 different
cities
it says we have a bomb that has more
powerful
that is more powerful than all of the
weaponry we have dropped
in europe in one bomb
if you're in one of these 12 cities
nagasaki
and uh and hiroshima were two of those
cities
please leave now if your country well if
your emperor will not surrender
we will be left with no choice but it is
so horrific
please take food and water and clothing
and
leave these cities we're not targeting
you
please leave those supplies will be in
very short supply afterwards you were
shot
if you picked one up wow what country
tells their people we're coming
we have this bomb we're going to drop it
by this date
and it's going to happen in one of these
cities well there's one country that
does it now but
the left's not thrilled with that
country right one
yeah how come we don't know about that
every time we hear about
america is so bad they always bring up
the atomic bomb
well can you throw this in this is
incredible yeah
this is an original letter to the hitler
youth from neville chamberlain
this talks about i welcome the intention
of the german
youth movement to devote a special issue
of the magazine
uh to uh your ideals in it he talks
about
he's met with the fuhrer he he's a man
of peace
and uh all the hopes of germany are set
upon you
hitler youth neville chamberlain
that one i got just because appeasement
never ever works listen to the last line
i mean i know you've read it but the
admirable motto of the year of
understanding
which you have chosen for the year of
1938 shows the part that you are playing
in this work
i mean talk about appeasement and
confusion
wow a couple of other things this is
wonderful read it
i ronald reagan do solemnly swear that i
will faithfully execute the office of
the president of the united
states and will to the best of my
ability preserve protect and defend the
constitution
of the united states so help me god
ronald reagan
january 20th 1980 and on the top
to nancy who brightens the cor is it the
corner
yeah who brightens every corner who
brightens or something
who brightens the corner where we are
yeah wow
so that that's the one that's the one
that was held
right in front of him as he was taking
the oath of office and how many people
how many people really mean that mean
that yeah
mean those words have you ever heard of
colonel uh stone uh
he was a guy he was
military actually the guy who
first protected kind of our first secret
service agent
first protected abraham lincoln when he
was coming in to
washington for the very first time he's
the guy who
who said we got to get you out we're
going to have you go into a theater
we're going to have you change clothes
you're gonna hunch over like a little
old lady
and we're gonna get you out the back
into a carriage and we're gonna hit you
on train take you to pittsburgh because
everybody's gonna think that you're
going to washington
we'll get you to pittsburgh then we'll
take another train into washington and
no one will know
it saved his life saved his life he
became
uh a colonel in um the
northern army in the fight in the civil
war
and he refused to hate the other side
he just thought they were wrong but he
refused to hate them that caused a lot
of problems with a lot of politicians
because they were
whipping up the hate it's why lincoln's
vice president walked out and was so
upset
it's why we have a picture of the only
picture
that is of john wilkes booth and abraham
lincoln
in the same picture and booth is behind
him and it's at the second inaugural
address and he actually tried to kill
him there
because he was so enraged that this guy
would say let's come together let's heal
these wounds he was enraged by that
and really wanted to kill him with his
own hands and attempted to do it
yeah well um
this colonel became a colonel in the
civil war
he was blamed for something that he
never did it was a trumped-up charge
because he became very unpopular with
with congress congress uh tried him
he wasn't allowed to even put on a
defense he wasn't allowed to speak in
front of congress
they never came to a verdict because
they know that it would have been
he would have been set free so he was
held
in prison he was held in prison i think
for about six months
lincoln found out about it and said what
the hell are you doing
charge him convict him or let him go
and they didn't they waited another six
or eight months
lincoln found out about it again and
just said get him out
he was so upset he went over he left the
united states
and he went over and he was working for
the french in egypt
years later he comes back he's thinking
he's hoping everybody is going to
forget about those things that they said
about him he's at home
he gets a knock on the door no one will
hire him they do remember no one will
hire him
he opens up the door it's two
representatives from the united states
government
and they said colonel we understand you
were in egypt and you were working with
the french
and he said yes and they said
so do you speak and read french
yes good because we just
got a big box of stuff and we don't know
how to put it together
it was the statue of liberty oh my god
this is
his purchase order for all of the stones
for the base of the statue of liberty
he's the guy the guy who could be the
worst on america has every reason to be
pissed
at america he builds the statue of
liberty
this is incredible colonel please inform
us at what
price you can furnish during the summer
of 1884
about 8 000 cubic yards of stone
according to the sample furnished to you
just that nuts just incredible
so this is this is an example
this is uh early american texting
okay do you know who um do you know who
uh matt anthony wayne is i feel that i
should
okay he's a general on our on the
american side
in the revolution he was great but he
was
he was an animal okay this is a picture
of him
in the uh in the
battle of i'm trying to remember which
battle the stony point so stony point he
shot in the head okay he's got a bullet
a big huge bullet in his head
and he keeps going and they're like
general general general and he's like
come on let's go
and so they win and they
uh they bring him in and they're like we
have to
get the bullet out of your head he's
like fine fine but
i need a piece of paper and and pencil
so this is his letter to george
washington
that says hey we won and it says it says
before he's got the bullet before he's
got the bullet he writes this letter
and it's from stony point 16 july
2 2 am dear general the fort and the
garrison with carol johnstone
are ours listen to this line
your officers and men behaved like
men who are determined to be free
i read that line and i thought what does
that even mean to live your life
determined to be free most americans
are not there so he writes it
to george washington george washington
it's folded up
george washington then takes it and he
puts it in his letter this is a letter
to
the governor who says hey i want to tell
you about the work here's
the colonel's message so he takes this
message puts it in his letter that's his
signature
uh no it's this it's one of these i
think this is
the washington signature no that's
george washington's signature there
yeah there he does it he puts that
letter in here he sends it to the
governor
this is the governor's letter where he
takes both of these letters
this is texting yeah this is early
american texas thank god that these
things exist
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our politics playlist
and if you want to watch full interviews
on a variety of topics watch our full
episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell